alright so go ahead and get started my
name is cliff Hastings this is kelvin
mishoe and our third co author is
michael morrison who's not here today
we're going to give you a talk on
writing the book the hands-on start to
mathematica book and some of the thought
processes that went into that and some
of them lessons that we learned through
that process as well so about the talk
the basic structure a little bit about
us some of the goals we meant to
accomplish the evolution to creating the
book we'll talk about a little bit on
the process of writing and editing that
we did Calvin will then talk about the
book itself and then we'll talk about
the marketing and sales process as well
as the lessons that we learned through
that process so a bit about us I went to
a small liberal arts college my
background was math I used a bunch of
tools in college but never learned any
of them we had six different software's
for six different classes and it wasn't
a very cohesive experience for me but I
also had no programming experience
either Michael in Kelvin Michael got his
bachelor's and master's in computer
science Kelvin his background with
psychology and engineering both them
were very strong programmers had lots of
programming experience lots of
background in and different languages
and tool sets at Wolfram Kelvin and I
became very fast friends we've been here
17 and 18 years respectively Michael was
here for 10 years and went on to work at
a university when i started at Wolfram I
started with the math mobile so people
would come see me at a university or
company there would be doors that drop
down to make ramps they would come in
and I would show them mathematica
through that process there were with an
inundation of different learning styles
and people who needed visual help they
needed audio held there's a lot of
different things so I knew I needed to
learn how to speak about mathematical
without overwhelming them but I also
couldn't dumb down Mathematica either
Michael and when he is at Wolfram he
started in tech support so he became
very comfortable with
technical questions about mathematic and
where our users fell short either in
very technical conversations or very
simplistic faq type questions and then
Kelvin Ashley started in customer
service so I had lots of conversations
with people about passwords and
activations in site license portal usage
so we all came from very different
backgrounds both in our education and
also here at Wolfram and then we
culminated that together by working in
the sales department for several years
together so when working in sales
together we would often meet and talk
about some of our wolfram goals so one
of our primary things we set out to work
on together was how to get a wider
spread usage of Mathematica and there
were three steps we thought and
identified to make that happen number
one we needed to give people more
repeatable statements about Mathematica
we would be at a conference we'd hear
somebody say hey Bob what is Mathematica
and everybody's answer was very
different it stumbled it seemed complex
so he wanted to give people repeatable
answers to that to help them educate
others about why they love Mathematica
number two we needed to get our current
users out of thinking of Mathematica
only for a very specific couple of tasks
symbolics graphics calculus the three
things we hear about a lot we needed to
get people out of just those thoughts of
their use of Mathematica and then
finally we have millions and millions of
people who love mathematical of our
brand really appreciate what it is the
tool does but very not enough of them
actually use it on a day-to-day basis we
need to get people that go from
appreciating to actually using so we
came up with three solutions to these
problems one of the repeatable
statements we created what was called
the Czech talk and all of our sales
people learn how to give a great talk on
Mathematica to universities the
company's the government labs to create
that repeatable statement lots and lots
of people saw the big picture value they
had quotes like this completely erases
my long-standing belief that math man
because too difficult for our students
that was great we were getting over that
repeatability hurdle but we didn't fix
that usage issue yet so number two then
we worked on a set of videos called the
hands-on start series this was a video
set to help students and faculties start
using Mathematica right away in courses
so we said if you'll use it in courses
or commercial people if you'll use it in
projects you don't have to spend the
time learning Mathematica or pay for it
we'll teach it for you in this video
series that was great got a lot of great
feedback got several hundred thousand
views of those videos but the issue was
that although people love them we
learned that really the video series was
a watch at once and done type medium
people students didn't want to go back
and re-watch the videos over and over
again so they they saw it they tried it
but then they wanted something a
resource to go back and stay on learning
Mathematica so that led us to the book
in writing the book so the the feedback
we got on the videos a lot was they were
so helpful because of the
approachability of the video and how how
non difficult it made Mathematica feel
and it really became approachable to
lots of students at junior colleges and
high schools and not just the chemical
engineering student at MIT type kid so
that was what we wanted to really think
about in writing the book how to make it
useful but also very approachable in the
process so there were several things
that Michael Kelvin and I worked on
quite a bit to create the book one was
creating a unified chapter structure we
wanted to feel like it had a lot of
depth in explanation of the Wolfram
language in Mathematica but it also
needed to stay very approachable as well
so the tone of the book changed many
many times up here i have three full
drafts of how it changed over time where
kelvin and michael are very good
programmers and very structural and
they're thinking their tone had a little
bit more of a textbook feel to it where
my tone is a little bit more
conversational so we talked a lot about
how to
envelop something that had both so a lot
of text explanations but then also we
have a section of notes in suggestions
throughout the book that feels much more
conversational and says okay Wolfram
language you should do this this and
this and this but this is a much easier
way to do it do it this way instead then
there's lots of examples throughout the
book individu there are assessment
questions to ensure you've understood
the chapter so faculty you can then
require it as part of a course have
students take the quizzes do those and
turn those in his assignments if they
show so choose we also worked a lot on
agreement on who the audience for the
book is the audience for Mathematica is
everyone but you can't write a book for
everyone without the risk of making it
again to dumb down or to high level for
a big audience so we really focused in
on the first time user of Mathematica or
those who have used mathematic in the
past are now returning it back to it for
the first time in quite a while we
wanted it to be anybody at any level
however whether it be vertical eyes
meaning student or commercial or teacher
so we spent a lot of time making sure
each chapter in each part of the text
was written for a student at MIT or
parkland college or high school or the
commercial person who's in a project for
the first time so we spades very special
attention to that and from my background
of being very are very good in
mathematics but not having a programming
background it was very important to me
that this book felt very approachable to
students who are in the maths or life
sciences or business or junior colleges
who have not had a strong programming
background that was very very important
to me and I think is a big part of this
book as well we talked a lot about
division of labor and making sure our
strengths were utilized in writing the
book as well again Michael and Kelvin
really wrote a lot of the book I didn't
have much of the creative the the actual
authorship of the book
my strengths were in creating the story
from start to finish making sure it
appeared many different types of
audiences and really focused on the new
user of mathematica writing the problem
sets and then my strength is just being
bossy so Kelvin and Michael wouldn't
working on things fast enough I would
just be bossy and make them get to
things and make sure we're on a timeline
we did a lot of sharing of documents
either via Dropbox or paper email we had
midnight chats whatever so since the
three of us all worked at Wolfram it is
very important we spent to us we didn't
want to spend work time on the book we
did this mostly evenings and weekends
for for quite a while and writing the
book the last step which is important to
you then is working with Wolfram media
so there were a couple of steps to that
in being an author we put together a
basic proposal we talked to Steven and
Andre about it they thought it was a
great idea and that's where Wolfram
media got resurfaced again I acted as
the primary legal context so I
negotiated the contract with Wolfram
media I set up an LLC on our behalf for
the book moving forward Michael acted is
the primary production contacts they
worked with the editing group and
publications and graphic design we had a
couple of collaborative meetings on
things like book cover and a few nuances
on just graphic design things but
overall it was a very easy and painless
process Kelvin's going to show the book
talk a little bit about the actual inner
workings of the book and then I'll wrap
up and talk a little bit about our sales
and marketing approach what we did to
get people to be aware of it and to
purchase it in some of the lessons we
learned from it go ahead Calvin okay
good so I'm going to show the actual
book itself when I was preparing this
talk it's a very you know I'm
emotionally invested in all the pages so
my instinct is for have to have this
talk be 30 hours long but I have 10
minutes so I'm going to fly in and out
of pages and give you comments so cliff
talked about what we wanted to
accomplish with the book that was an
extension of the video and extend
other things that we wanted to do when
we started writing the book this became
very tangible very quickly even just
making the outline of the chapters and
and the what we wanted to cover in terms
of content first thing we really wanted
to do that was important to us was to
grab the reader's interest right away to
make sure that they pay attention to
make sure that they're excited about
Mathematica we also wanted a slow
build-up of material so cliff mentioned
the differences in backgrounds the
programmers the non-programmers so this
slow build-up helps anyone ramp into
using Mathematica successfully and we
wanted to do the full scope of
Mathematica so cliff mentioned this as
well there are many great books on how
to use Mathematica in a certain
discipline in a certain area those books
exist and they're very good so we didn't
want to write another book like that our
focus is specifically on Mathematica and
the full scope of of the actual software
itself so my first pillar here grab the
in the readers interest right away so
the the we accomplish that with the
first two chapters so the first chapter
called the very basics it encouraged the
readers to actively do something right
away so it's minimal explanation it's
having the reader type some things work
long to do something to have some
successful plots and successful 3d plots
to see something really neat but really
to engage them and get them doing
something then once they are tuned in
chapter 2 is a sample project in
Mathematica so our two goals were to
show what's possible once you're
proficient in Mathematica and then it
motivates people to read on and then go
through the actual syntax conventions so
I'll show chapter 2 here good so I'm
showing PDFs here keep in mind the
notebooks look very similar to the PDFs
so we had a custom style sheet that we
used for the authoring of the book we
had a custom palette so things that are
in a different font because their proper
Wolfram language functions or things
that are shift enter we did that all
while we authored
that's the beauty of a stylesheet so the
post-production and the design cliff
mentioned that Michael is more involved
in that but it went very quickly I mean
it looked it looked in notebook how it
looks in print very good in both so
chapter 2 our sample project in
Mathematica we talked about how
mathematic is the perfect software to do
a project like this and then we pose a
question so we say what part of the
world has the highest life expectancy we
talk about how people might answer this
question and the pitfalls of doing this
maybe you go out to the web and do a
search maybe you use another software
package but we talked about how
mathematic is great with this we start
very simply so we start answering this
just with one country life expectancy in
the US then we get to how to answer this
in terms of country data in terms of
Wolfram language and then as cliff
mentioned right away this is a how did
you describe it sort of comment yeah so
this right away is the is one of the big
points of these we call them spiky boxes
so these are our tips and tricks but
throughout the book we are comparing
contrasting different approaches to do
the same thing why would you want to use
free form input why would you want to
use country data what is one good when
is the other good what pitfalls are you
going to run into and those are our tips
and they are they are early and often
throughout the book so by page six here
then we get to the actual answer so we
build up the what we're doing and so
then we start to answer this question
where we look at the countries in South
America and we start to answer who has
the the largest life expectance or the
yes the longest life expectancy so we're
only on page six then we can go a little
bit farther and then we can say well
wouldn't it be interesting to look at
this not just as life expectancy but
let's look at something else like infant
mortality fraction and let's compare the
two for all the countries in the world
and see if they have a relationship and
then if you're going to compare to
or if you're going to swap in any sort
of differences or variations in data or
anything really manipulate is the way to
do that of course and so then you can
look at life expectancy versus GDP
versus literacy fraction versus all
these things so not only did we answer
our original question but then we showed
that this is the habit of mathematical
users you start out with one question
and then five other really interesting
questions occur to you as you go and you
start to tackle those questions as well
so we wanted to convey that excitement
we wanted to convey what it felt like to
be a mathematical user so then people go
through the rest of the book I talked
about there we go so I also talked about
a slow build-up of material so the next
several chapters chapter three chapter
five these are chapters that outline
more of the basics of Mathematica so
input and output starts with exactly
what you think it would shift enter and
then it goes to the the suggestions bar
and the cell insertion input and then we
get into freeform input there we go so
then in the first chapter we're compare
and contrast this is Wolfram language
this is freeform input this is the layer
on top of Mathematica and what that does
and then as we go here so if I skip to
page 15 then we're talking about
predictive interface and creating this
nice template how that fits in with free
form input and then let's see and if I
skip back to page 12 so I think the pros
and cons of all this this is what you
would expect this chapter to be but all
along the way we've got these nice tips
and tricks so this one is on triple
clicking we find I mean this is one
example of lots in this book but we find
this is just a really good simple habit
for people to get into it's a good way
to parse what they've typed it's a good
way to figure out where an expression
begins and ends so there are a lot of
things that we recommend in the very
early chapters that that
pay dividends down the road another very
simple thing see what page that's on 18
so this is something that falls in the
should be obvious but we have been asked
this who knows how many times n times
how do you enter a fraction how do you
make the input look like the output how
do you do that with a palette how do you
do that with a keyboard shortcut so all
these things that people really want to
do when they start using Mathematica
it's not just about syntax it's about
the things that people people really
want to do so that's the third chapter
then the fifth chapter gets into
fundamentals of Wolfram language so here
we talk about more conventions and and
to keep me from showing all 450 pages I
have a little card here to keep me from
not showing the entire thing okay so
fundamentals this is more conventions
like variable assignments so we talked
about defining variables however we
talked about it in a tone that is
accessible to anyone so we point out if
you have a calculation like this where
you find yourself re typing something
like 10 plus 20 minus 15 and you type
that over and over and over again a
variable is a great way to avoid
repetition so this is not a computer
science explanation this is a very
practical problem-solving explanation
for why you would want to do these
things in Mathematica same thing with
units and symbols so we start to talk
about the quantity function the quantity
framework how to convert those things
but then before that we talked about
it's a little farther than I thought
yeah before that we talked about you
might start just using regular symbols
for units and we talked about that's a
common way to start how that can be an
easy way to do things but then the pros
and cons and when you really want to get
into free form input the Wolfram Alpha
data or quantity and the advantages of
each of them then the next thing so data
filtering and manipulation so I'm going
to skip way ahead here to chat
20 but here we're in a we're in a
chapter where we've already talked about
importing data things like that I'm
going to skip ahead to the part command
so here we're talking about the part
command not with abstract examples but
we actually import some data and talk
about immediately where's part going to
be useful so if you've got a data set
which is first name last name and then
some sort of sample score intuitively
you're going to wonder how do I get just
the scores how do i extract just that
information or how do I get the first
name last name how do I grab out that
information so we're setting this up
where the reader asks their own
questions as they go and then we tell
them the part command is the solution to
that same with the select function so it
pages that on 24 so again we're
importing data we're talking about oh
I'm sorry I skipped ahead to
associations so with select and append
to in cases we're talking about adding
data cleaning up data filtering data but
practical reasons of why you'd want to
do that we present the Select function
where the thought process is not to
learn this all at once but to define
what how you want to select things and
then and then the two lists of what you
want to select so we've avoided pure
functions we've made decisions like that
where this is a good introduction where
we're building up the content bit by bit
associations also are covered where
we've talked about lists and nested
lists and then we talked about some of
the new things like how to take your
data set and create an association and
what the advantages are once you're
working in that association or data set
framework so those are just a few of the
things we're we're looking at the the
build-up of material then we wanted to
focus on the scope so i'll show the
table of contents
I think this and the last point are
related so the first nine chapters of
the book let me make that bigger there
we go so the first nine chapters of the
book they are meant to be read in order
so they are the prerequisites for the
book so we assume that all the readers
have read basic input/output slideshows
fundamentals of the Wolfram language
these things that are the basics to get
started then after that we've written
the book where people can skip around so
some people might get the book and jump
straight to calculus I think a lot of
people will jump straight to graphics
some people will jump straight to data
or programming but these do not they
don't build on each other by chapter
they build on the concepts within the
chapter so they start simple within the
chapter and build up in complexity but
you can skip ahead and read the data
filtering chapter without reading
chapters 10 through 19 so we do this
build up of material but we also have
have made things broad we're different
people with different interests they can
jump in and they can learn but they can
learn the things that they're interested
in first rather than reading 23 chapters
or 22 chapters just to then get to
statistics which is what they cared
about in the first place so that's the
structure of the chapters and then I'm
going to turn it back over to cliff
alright so a few of the things we did to
market the book on the marketing side we
did a bunch of free hands-on start
training courses which was very
successful ran six back to school
courses we had 1,800 attendees of 4,600
registrants a lot were students and
that's who we had marketed this training
to it was a two hour training event
which I trained from pieces of the book
and it was very successful sixty percent
had not used Mathematica prior to this
to our course in twenty-five percent had
not even installed it before they got
this email about the course so I was
very happy to see it was a bunch of
students who were learning for the first
time and using it for that first course
in back to school from the the sales
perspective we've had a lot of success
amazon sold out twice and is almost sold
out again so that's been pretty nice and
we're working on getting more of
international presence with that on
these next few weeks and how to get it
translated and get it to other places in
in non-english writing and also in the
e-book side as well one thing we did I
think was pretty smart we created a
unique code for each book on the back of
the book is a code in which when people
get it they can do a couple of things
one they can request the answer key for
the problem sets if they have that
unique code and then they could also
take one of these classes which is
normally fifty dollars they can get it
for free and then we get contact
information for who buys the book we
don't use it for anything weird I just
like the opportunity to interact with
them and say hey you bought the book
how's it going what are your thoughts so
far what can I help you with and in the
purchaser's seem very happy to interact
with the authors on those things that's
been very nice a few lessons we learned
collaboration and passion was the
definite key even here in Kelvin talk
about pure functions I remember us
having a long drawn-out fight about
whether pure functions would be in this
book or not and that's been a fun thing
we had so we we had a good experience
with those arguments and discussions
along the way we took a lot longer than
necessary again we wanted to do it
completely outside of work so and we
also wanted it to be a good book to
market Mathematica as well so we would
constantly say did you see that new
thing coming in version 11 or version 12
maybe we should wait until that comes
and finally we just had to say no no we
got to get this book out and get it done
that code I talked about is on the back
cover but it is hidden like Fort Knox so
we have learned not to do that is as
tricky as it has been I think that again
the fact that we come from very
different backgrounds mathematic it was
really helpful there were many times
calvin and michael would write something
i would read it and I couldn't
understand it they were so excited about
it and loved it but if I couldn't
understand it neither would half the
audience we were trying to attract to
the book as well so I think it worked
out really well that we had multiples of
us collaborating on the book and last
thing I would say is just make sure if
you're interested in writing a book have
a pricing strategy upfront that helped
us understand how much more time how
many more pages should it be color
should it be big should it have a pool
binding to it should it have a regular
binding has a lot of questions along the
way we haven't thought about but that
pricing structure helped that a lot